[Music]  celebrities are showing their support at  March for our lives thank you so much  for fighting for change and for safety  Ariana Grande was among the performers  in Washington DC on Saturday along with  Miley Cyrus and Demi Lovato  George and Amal Clooney lin-manuel  Miranda and Ben Platt and Jennifer  Hudson were also among those protesting  gun violence and mass shootings Sir Paul  McCartney attended a demonstration in  New York City the former Beatle was  honoring his friend the late John Lennon  who was shot and killed in 1980  Kim Kardashian and Kanye West brought  daughter North to the DC March with Kim  tweeting I'm so happy I got to share  this moment with these two  I hope North remembers this forever  meanwhile Miley Cyrus shared the moment  with her mother and sisters  [Music]  [Applause]